all right guys what is going on today we
are talking quick hitches for your
tractor we're gonna try to keep it brief
free today just explain what these quick
hitches are how they can help you why
they're so popular we're gonna try to
hit a lot of highlights about quick
hitches and just give you some
differences in some similarities to help
you make a better decision I'm going to
attempt to answer why you may want a
quick hitch for your tractor but let's
be real this is just what I had an
inventory here okay so there's four
different manufacturers right here these
are four different quick hitches that
all essentially do the same thing for
you this is not a complete
representation of what's on the market
right now it's just what I had in
inventory at the time I always want to
provide objective information and that
can be challenging being a dealer for
just some of these quick hitches here
because obviously I'll make money if I
sell you the ones that I represent right
however part of my business model is to
sell things that are a good value so
whatever dollar amount that you're
spending you're getting a very good
value for that dollar amount otherwise
it just doesn't make sense to me why
would you want to buy it I say all of
that to say I try to be objective some
of this is subjective I just can't help
it but I want to give you an honest
assessment and I'll just give you my
opinion on why I sell these certain
quick itches and I don't the others some
of them I just don't have the
opportunity to all I want to do is
answer some of those questions and let
you make that decision we're gonna get
started here in just a second but really
quick if you haven't done so yet hit
that subscribe button below also if you
just google good works tractors you'll
find my facebook page head there if
you're on facebook click like I put a
lot of cool stuff on there as well i'm
also on instagram so follow me on there
and last but not least follow good works
tractors calm i'd love to put together a
tractor package for you show you an
attachment answer any question you might
have good works tractors calm all right
here we go okay so i want to start off
by saying there's one thing i'm not
gonna talk about and that is how to hook
up a quick hitch to your tractor or hook
up a quick hitch to your attachment i
have done some other what i think are
pretty good videos about that i'm gonna
post links above here so at some point
this video here if you want to watch how
to use a quick hitch or how to hook it
up to your tractor click on one of those
links and you can check that out as well
after you're done watching this video
it's an easy process to do but it's kind
of a process in and of itself and i
don't want to take time away from just
kind of going over what these are in
general here and answering some specific
questions about them okay
first up let's go over the similarities
here now you're gonna see all these look
extremely similar and they should and
there's a reason for that there's an a
sae specification that controls the
dimensional spacing of these quick
hitches and so there's going to be
tolerances within there that they have
to conform to so every quick hitch you
see here in every quick hitch on the
market should conform to that a sae
specification if you don't see where it
says that and occasionally I might not
put that in my description as well just
ask a question to the manufacturer or to
me or to your dealer and they can
confirm that it was built in that a sae
specification oftentimes you're going to
hear about compatibility issues between
quick hitches and attachments that don't
match together they don't meet they
don't fit together like they're supposed
to and on a rare occasion even I will
have that happen with either an
attachment or a quick hitch so within
this specification it's a pretty tight
parameter that these quick hitches and
the attachments all have to fit within
and so you have a spacing measurement
that's going to be between these lower
links down here and then you also have a
spacing measurement that's going to go
from the lower links to the upper link
so you will see that all these quick
hitches are gonna have bolt holes that
are on the top link okay to allow you to
adjust it up and down that's gonna aid
in compatibility and flexibility with
the attachments so I said on occasion I
do have something that doesn't match up
well there it's a quick hitch or the
attachment or a combination of both the
match just isn't there and so again with
these tolerances being so tight and so
narrow with everything having to fit and
match up occasionally you are gonna have
an attachment that doesn't quite just
fit the bill you know and so you can
accomplish that by a couple of ways
either shave off a little bit of
material sometimes even just a little
bit of paint or you can simply send it
back get a new one and hopefully that
cures the problem however I'm telling
you 99 out of 100 probably more like 999
out of a thousand times I don't have an
issue with this okay I brought the
camera down low here that way you can
see what I want to talk about next and
that is gonna be the cross bracing or
the support between the top and the side
as you can see pretty chunky and beefy
on some of these okay these black ones
here you can see in the corners there a
lot of chunky bracing the imesh doesn't
actually have that kind of
same a little bit of racing but not the
same amount this is a land pride up here
okay and you can see there's some cross
bracing there just a thin plate of steel
on the far side alright and so all of
these quick hitches will be rated for at
least up to 40 horsepower if not higher
I've used them on many four series
tractors without issue so I think you
know as with a lot of farm equipment
they are also term over built before
what they're gonna be on and I don't
really think you're gonna have much of
an issue unless you are really just
pushing the limits of your tractor so
the difference there in the cross
bracing just shows you one of the ways
that these quick itches can be
constructed differently while remaining
within the same dimensional tolerances
of that ASAE specification one of the
other big ways that they can vary is by
weight and that's what we're gonna do
next we're gonna go ahead and weigh each
one of these quick hitches and we'll
show you how much they weigh you know
what before we weigh these we're gonna
go ahead and give you a little
background information on these quick
hitches here so number one these are all
category one three-point quick hitches
okay so they're not going to be category
two no limited cat1 so like the smaller
land prides are not included in here
this is all apples to apples to apples
to apples as best as possible okay so
now let me tell you about each one of
these quick itches here in particular
mountain on my 1025 here is gonna be a
work saver quick hitch this is
manufactured in the USA and Litchfield
Illinois okay so now for the sales pitch
so there's a few reasons why I like
these work favorite quick hitches and
why I choose to sell them I can sell a
lot of different manufacturers I really
love selling these work saver quick
hitches so reason one they're gonna
include a set of these bushings these
bushings are required they're gonna go
on the bottom pins of any attachment
that you put on your three-point hitch
okay so you really want to have a set of
these bushings for every attachment that
you're gonna hook up to your three-point
hitch yes some guys will take these off
and put them on to the next attachment
however that really defeats the purpose
of having a quick hitch in the first
place which is efficiency so the work
saver is gonna include linchpins here
while the I match for sure includes
cotter pins these are just a nice
convenience to have if you're attaching
and detaching your quick hitch a lot of
folks just leave their quick hitch on
and never comes off but if you need to
attach it to a non
package compatible attachment you want
to take the quick hitch off or maybe
have a backhoe you want to put on
something along those lines it's nice to
have a really easy pin to work with here
versus the kind that once you kind of
deform it it's a real pain to kind of
work with and get it back together to go
through the hole and you got to use the
wires you know what I mean so it's just
a nice convenience it's not the end of
the world they'll both get the job done
but just a nice touch by work saver work
saber includes what's called a floating
top link or floating top link adapter
something along those lines you'll hear
it called multiple things and so this
opens up the versatility so if you do
have some non quickhitch compatible
attachments you can put this in place of
the top hook that's on the quick Ajit's
elf and get a lot of flexibility there
up and down that kind of thing so I'll
show you what I mean so the last reason
I really like these work saver quick
hitches is that they include this extra
bracket here called a top link adapter
and you can put this on you can take off
that hook which I've done here you can
take this hook off okay that would
normally go right in here and you can
put this on and this is a floating top
link adapter here and it allows you
almost infinite adjustment to hook up to
a top link on an attachment okay so if
you have a specifically a non-quick
hitch compatible attachment or something
that just has a really goofy top link to
it you can put this on you can actually
shorten your draw bars as much as
possible so this kind of angles in so
it's not sticking out extending way
beyond the vertical point if you don't
want it to and make it work so this is
also included with the work saver quick
hitch so a nice bonus from work savers
the fact that they're manufactured in
Litchfield Illinois right here in the
USA okay so this one here is Al and
pride QH 15 it came in on an L Series
Kubota a while back this kind of kept it
on hand so folks you'll see what they
are and you'll see it's got the multiple
holes in the top link which is a great
feature as well to adjust that top link
up and down or the top hook I should say
very similar construction to the others
you'll note that difference there in the
cross bracing underneath take a look at
the backside here so you can see that
look on the far side and then right
there okay this guy here is the popular
John Deere I match
the nice thing is you can get these in
green I can't sell the work savers in
green unfortunately take a look at the
cross-bracing there okay again multiple
locations to adjust that top hook very
similar construction this guy here is at
our River this is very similar to a
Harbor Freight quickhitch
okay good channeling their cross bracing
really the rest of its similar in
construction again he had the adjustment
there for the top hook okay so we're
gonna weigh these now I put this piece
of steel here simply because they're
u-shaped and I want something to open up
at the top up here let the legs hang
down and hopefully rest on here and then
I zeroed out the scale so 0.0 right now
with this piece of steel on here as well
okay so the land pride QH 15 weighs in
at 68 point four pounds next up here is
the John Deere I match okay sixty five
point eight pounds okay this one here is
the Tar River quick hitch this is
similar to a Harbor Freight okay you'll
see 50 6.0 pounds okay last one up here
is the work saver quick hitch 71 point
two for the work saver quick hitch okay
alright so those kind of results are
ones that speak for themselves you can
see what the weight is you can see what
you're paying for then right so weights
kind of speak for themselves right you
know I mean you can kind of tell with
more cross bracing you would think that
the work saver would weigh more than the
I match and the land pride however the
work saver looks very similar to the tar
river but what was there there was a 15
16 pound difference between the work
saver and the tar river
the work saver ended up being the
heaviest out of the bunch there so
perhaps that's attributed to more cross
bracing perhaps a little bit thicker
steel something along those lines okay
so I'm going to go ahead and grab a
critical dimension here on all of these
which is a centerline to centerline of
the lower link points here I'm really
not worried about lower to upper because
all of these again have the adjustable
positions here so you really have a lot
of flexibility with them they're more
concerned about left to right on the two
lower links let's see what the work
saver reads here we're looking at about
twenty eight and a quarter next here
we'll do the land pride and again this
is very approximate you know don't hold
me to it
but we're very close here 28 and a
quarter-inch now let's do the John Deere
I match the John Deere I match is about
28 and a half Center to Center let's
take a look at the tar river there tar
river is 28 and a half as well Center to
Center okay so what we can see here is
they're all within a quarter inch and
that's again I'm just put it down and
run the tape across I'm not exactly I'm
trying to get close to center to center
there but it's not this is not
scientific okay this is just to get you
close enough and I can tell you that a
quarter inch is close enough for this
measurement here okay so now let's touch
on cost or price and I really don't want
to put specific prices in here
because this video lasts for years and
years and prices fluctuate and change
over time however I can say that if
we're gonna compare new to new - new -
new - new I don't know how all four of
them across the board new I can tell you
that that tar river similar to a Harbor
Freight is going to be at the lowest end
price point okay this can be the
cheapest one you can get then you step
up to another tier which is really where
the work saver and the I match and the
land prides and a lot of the more
quality more robust manufactured quick
hitches are gonna be at and I can tell
you that what I found is the land pride
is the most expensive with the I match
following closely behind it and then the
work saver being actually the cheapest
among those three and so again you get
the work saver with that floating top
link adapter which sometimes is valuable
sometimes not
that you get that extra set of bushings
and you also get the convenience of
those pins which some of them come with
and some of them don't but it's just
nice to know that the work saver does
and again those work savers are made in
the USA right in the Litchfield Illinois
which is a bonus
I know buddies aren't all the options
but I thought four was a pretty good
representation at some different levels
and price points and manufacturers
especially some from the major
manufacturers out there with John Deere
and Kubota
and their sister companies or partner
companies with their attachments so I
felt like it was a pretty fair
representation hey make sure you leave a
comment below I'd love to hear from you
I get things wrong sometimes we all
learn something new every day when we
get smarter but some of these things
speak for themselves today and I'll let
you make your own decision on the right
quick hitch for you